episode 88 of congratulations is brought
to you by the cash app you already know
the cash up is number one finance app on
the App Store what you might not know is
you can also put cash up in your wallet
with the cash card
it's got boosts it's got boosts it's got
boosts it's got great safety features no
credit check needed to get one we'll
talk about this more later on in the
show
download the cash up for free on the App
Store or Google Play market and blast
off my babies blast my babies dude I got
an email from my let's go over some
before we even get started I want to
talk about my tour coming up well coming
up it's been going on but the
follow-the-leader tour
Miami is coming up so all the Miami
babies
we got a few tickets left you know I'm
assuming it's gonna sell out it's a big
venue but uh you know you might want to
get your tickets now go to Chris D'Elia
calm and get tickets for the follow the
leader tour we've got Miami coming up so
the Miami babies we need those South
Florida Cuban babies to come out and
wear your CUDA shirts your no CUDA
shorts rather we've got a bunch of dates
I just got emailed from my manager and
my and my agent that a lot of these
dates are selling out the New York
Washington DC Montclair New Jersey
Portland Snoqualmie they're all sold out
one of the Vancouver ones is sold out
the other show and Vancouver has about
has a few tickets left West Palm Beach
Florida Jacksonville Florida
Atlanta Georgia there's still some
tickets left on the second show Los
Angeles California we just added a new
show we're at The Wiltern twice now you
boy you're the babies the LA babies come
out man we really we really grassroots
did up in here up in this LA market San
Francisco Boston that's all gone
adding a show tomorrow and went Medford
to the bigger theater we did four
we'll Wilber shows and they're all sold
out that's amazing Boston has love does
a cult is strong in Boston Fresno
California Bakersfield California Austin
Texas San Antonio Texas we've got a
bunch of a bunch of these shows coming
up get your tickets now because they're
most likely I mean all the shows been
selling out so get on there Miami babies
you're up next so here we are we are in
the we're in October babies are you
feeling spooky are you feeling spooky I
wonder how many people are gonna go as
Takashi's as the that chick Jakarta
Takashi six nine she's [ __ ] so
weirdly sexy you know I mean um I hope
she finds a [ __ ] good guy soon but
she she's she's Takashi six none and is
just so you know a lot of people are
gonna put that six nine on their [ __ ]
head and then go as to cut and go
scratchy snakes nine they're gonna get
some far the six nine on their head and
they're gonna do the rainbow bright hair
and they're gonna put some some guys are
gonna put some fake titties in and
they're gonna go as [ __ ] too cushy
six nine and I'll tell you what dude
that's gonna be that's gonna be a
[ __ ] popular costume let me ask you a
question hey sink ah she's six nine why
the [ __ ] are you always so angry you've
got you've got it you made it baby you
know yeah you've got Rainbow Brite hair
you do whatever the [ __ ] you want you
got tats all over your body six nine is
all over your body but let me ask you
pretty little lady why the [ __ ] are you
so angry every video I see of you on
worldstar or whatever the [ __ ] you've
got billions of dollars you've got a
Ferrari painted like the [ __ ] like
like it like the whoever made the
artwork for the Yellow Submarine of the
Beatles you're riding across Dubai and
you're always like is your [ __ ] is
stupid
why are you so mad to can see why are
you so mad crippled on Qi why are you so
upset
you made it you've got eighty million
dollars
you're giving money to your mom you've
got a great mother-daughter relationship
what the [ __ ] wrong man you got props
why you so upset
that's what I want to know cap lechi Sam
firing I want to know why you're so
upset what's the deal what is it
every [ __ ] video you [ __ ]
is you stupid you thought I couldn't
have a number-one song who thought that
I didn't even think about you why are
you such an upset low girl yo you stupid
you thought I couldn't have a number-one
song you thought I could these
[ __ ] thought I couldn't do it
it's just stupid it's just stupid man I
thought you thought I could have
[ __ ] I got on an American
Billboard I made a Spanish song it's
just stupid I got number one I hit the
Billboard oh speaking in Spanish on the
American Billboard is who [ __ ] is stupid
and then I'll do a video like it's
really important for you to love your
daughter
don't be stupid as you stupid car plunge
in 75 why you so mad that's what I want
to know man be okay be happy one day
you'll find a good man
and you'll be so [ __ ] happy you'll
make a great housewife right now thought
it up on the Instagram why do you what
why don't what is up these rappers and
then they're like why do they get robbed
dude they walk around with a Gucci bag
full of [ __ ] $70,000 and they're like
and then then the next thing you hear is
got robbed walking around bulletproof
vests on they can avoid all this [ __ ]
it's hilarious walking around with a
bulletproof vest on carrying $70,000 hey
don't carry $70,000 you won't need to
put on a bulletproof vest God the fact
that hip-hop became not about the music
anymore is just incredible
I'm doing a podcast talking in Spanish
and Craig bleh I'm trying to use your
stupid I'm top ten I'm top 20
oh I hit number 14 on the comedy podcast
it's just stupid I'm saying this
incredibly you'll never understand when
I'm born is a stupid my pussy's wet dog
anyway
shout out the [ __ ] completed site
sign but also you know if you're gonna
get it I love how people are like I knew
if I have a buddy who was like I went
all out and got all the tattoos all over
my body because I knew what [ __ ] make
me head on into music but somebody was
like I don't remember who was it was
like I don't remember who was I think it
was that guy Kodak black and he was like
no I don't think it was him it was
somebody that has tattoos all over the
face and they were like they were like
yeah I got tattoos on my face cuz I knew
that it would make me not get a real job
and do music and be successful in music
and then somebody replied hey just don't
apply for a job imagine being that
hardcore and being like well [ __ ] man I
certainly don't want to [ __ ] I
certainly don't want to work retail
guess I gotta [ __ ] go go get across
in between my eyes I don't want to I
don't want to do retail guess I gotta go
[ __ ] get the the saw puppet on my
cheek tattooed tattooed on my cheek ah
ten kanji six nines has [ __ ] the saw
puppet on a tricycle on his cheek is
that Takashi six Niner is that the
[ __ ] guy who's that other guy
skittles what's his [ __ ] name bullets
some [ __ ] guy's name who's the guy
stitches oh yeah it's Takashi saps nine
this kid stitches dude that guy stitches
is a guy who has the [ __ ] who had the
[ __ ] the beef with the game and then the
game [ __ ] knocked him out you know
he's got two pock tattooed on his
forehead and also a teddy bear
oh how ironic is that man how have
[ __ ] silly is that man I cool man so
you're hardcore and
also but you got a soft heart though I
love all these rappers are like yo man
they make all these songs like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] that but then like they're like but
yo you gotta make this song it's like yo
I'm a real person
I love that [ __ ] dude when rappers are
like yo I made this music you know it's
about getting deeper and it's about me
speaking to really who I truly am and
then it's like they have a song and it's
like [ __ ] leave your back door open
[ __ ] leave your back door open [ __ ]
leave your back door open I'm about to
Skeet Skeet Skeet Uranus and it's like
yeah but I got a full heart Dawg you
know I'm just trying to grow with my
music that's what they say all the time
that's what they say all the time I'm
just trying to grow as artists you know
trying to grow as an artist Skeet Skeet
Skeet any anus Skeet Skeet Skeet any
anus oh my little sodas in your heinous
let's let's play any anus cream just
trying to grow with the music you know I
mean leave you back [ __ ] let your back
door open I [ __ ] you [ __ ] your mama it's
so [ __ ] you know hey holy kid um it's
just incredible it's just incredible
it's incredibly he's you're stupid
it's incredibly he's you stupid um I
don't know man
I just I think that hip-hop is just
[ __ ] insane hey love pump hey Kanye
Kanye with this [ __ ] maggot hat dude
he had his mega hot and then DJ poo put
under the Instagram music ain't getting
attention that was hilarious I thought
that was the [ __ ] ultimate [ __ ]
burn like such a hardcore burn to be
like Magga and then Kanye's light and
then and then DJ Pooh writes music ain't
gettin attention Beach
that's some [ __ ] [ __ ] your [ __ ]
you fat [ __ ] dude remember DJ
poo you guys probably don't man he had
that one sup baron amber I am Pam brown
all right
anyway horrible representation of it but
really good in my head so um you ever do
that with your friend though you're like
you're like oh no it's the it's the song
that goes like [ __ ] you know and then
you do this song whatever it is and
they're like I don't know if I heard it
and you're like nah here it is and you
play it and you're like that's what I
was doing here like no wasn't you
[ __ ] idiot you're tone deaf
but yeah
Kanye West on SNL it's so crazy that
he's just like talking about it oh man
and then I saw a meme wait and then I
saw a meme about George Bush where he
had George Bush's face and then on top
of said Kanye West does not care about
black people like how [ __ ] Kanye I
said that about George Bush dude it's so
crazy that [ __ ] cono is is so it's
actually kind of I think he's got a real
problem and he's obviously bipolar or
something the guy's got to get some help
man I mean you know I guess he seems
he's doing okay he's making money and
he's got a good family I guess I don't
know he's got a [ __ ] kid and then a
good wife or whatever huh is I'm not
sure is it uh it may be ah and maybe a
drive-by ahead but I'm not sure I don't
know he's trolling but he's been
trolling man he's been trolling
everything he does he's like I mean he
dressed up as [ __ ] Harry a worst
outfit of all time I mean dude he had
the [ __ ] boxy shoulders and then
dressed up as Perrier and they'll pump
dressed up as Fiji head I don't know I
don't know anymore man and then he gave
that speech after Saturday alive and
like four people clapped and there were
hundreds of people in the audience he
was talking about dogs from and one guy
was just like but hip-hop is
[ __ ] crazy god dude it's so out to
lunch
it's so out to lunch because of camp
Watchi pics 9 and [ __ ] guys like
Kodak Blanc
dude Kodak black how about did you guys
see the [ __ ] the basketball player
what's his name who did the laughs the
meme cowboy Leonard by the way I didn't
know here's how much of personality
matters in basketball I didn't know who
he was and apparently he's a superstar
player but like guys like LeBron you
know and and and even other guys Steph
Curry
they developed a personality what's his
name Kelly what car we Leonard Kauai
Hawaii the [ __ ] VIP lay this Hawaii
Leonard laughs I'm gonna play this laugh
for you if you don't know about it but
Jesus Christ it sounds like the most
insecure jay-z of all time yourself and
what would you like people to know about
you there we go listen I'm a fun guy oh
really
obviously I love the game of basketball
I'm a fun guy I mean there's just more
question you have to ask me in order for
me to tell you about myself look let me
tell you something first of all before
we get into the insecure laugh this guy
plays basketball I respect this guy he
doesn't give a [ __ ] about the [ __ ] he
doesn't have necessarily an outgoing
crazy [ __ ] superstar personality but
whatever he doesn't need to he's all
about the basketball apparently is one
of the best in the game props to this
[ __ ] guy props this guy also for
doing this they were probably like get
out there and do the thing they're like
what do you want people to know about
you and he says I'm a fungi i'm a fungi
every note is the same if you're talking
and every note is the same dude talking
is musical you know what I mean when I'm
talking I go up I say oh this kind of
[ __ ] and I
go lay down they say hey man Nana
oh really all I'm doing is hypnotizing
you right you learned how to say certain
stuff as a comedian you think about that
all the time you go to it you talk about
this
mana and then pahahahah everyone laughs
this guy's just like I'm a fun guy
of course it's not gonna work you're not
going to get people on your side
personality-wise now here is the rest of
the this can't give you a whole spiel
oh my in order for me to tell you about
myself I just can't give you a whole
spiel oh so robot just in order for me
to tell you about myself I just can't
give you a full spiel unless you ask
specific questions I don't even know
where you said Natalie I mean there's
just more question you have to ask me in
order for me to tell you about myself I
just can't give you a whole spiel I
don't even know where you said Natalie
[Laughter]
in order were you sitting there I just
don't even know where you sitting at
that was the best part that was a part
where you realize Oh wash my hands of
this do you know what I mean he was just
like you know in order to tell you what
I'm like you gotta get more specific I
just can't give you a full spill I don't
even know where you're sitting at hey
hey man you're a robot listen that whole
thing again how robotic it is how crazy
is it to have a personality but that's
what they said about Steph Curry in the
beginning and that dude lit it up
yourself and what would you like people
to know about you
first of all speaking of the mic I'm a
fun guy
obviously I love the game of basketball
I mean there's just more question you
have to ask in order for me to tell you
about myself you just can't give you a
whole spiel I don't even know where you
sit in comments laughter I mean dude you
got to see the video - you got to see
his mouth do it it's weird as [ __ ] it
looks like a Simpson all of a sudden he
looks like what he looks like when that
guy at [ __ ] at the the drunk in the
Simpsons burps that when it goes and all
the [ __ ] sir
and secure hey man easy just say man you
know what you know what it is - this
guy's probably I mean he's how old is he
like 24 maybe that's the thing man when
I was 22 I remember being at before I
did stand-up and before I became a
[ __ ] thick skinned individual because
of bombing for so much I got
construction in the house sorry if you
hear it [ __ ] whatever disrespectful
but the he's 27 years old when I was 22
I remember I broke up with a girl a girl
broke up with me broken my heart and
then I was like you know what I am gonna
go out I'm gonna go my but it's like
come on come out let's go let's go hang
out we'll get you you talk to some
chicks you know we'll get you out
[ __ ] be good and I'm like all right I
don't really like going out but I go out
to this part went out to this bar called
nicks in Beverly Hills and it was a
party that he knew everybody there and I
didn't know anybody there and there was
a really cute girl there and I thought
you look like Britney Spears and this
back when Britney Spears was like the
[ __ ] hottest you know the number one
[ __ ] to me the archetype of like oh
my god how does she give her so so I was
like she was in our conversation I was
like what do I say to this girl in my
head I was like what do i do how do I
talk and then I would say things and
every time I said something I was like
how come these [ __ ] words are coming
out of my mouth
I don't want to sound like this but
everything single time she said
something she be like oh well what else
did this and that and I'd be like
basically
it's weird
I was 22 then I got a stage started
bombing a lot and then didn't give a
[ __ ] about anything that laughs
literally sounds more like busting and
not than laughing it actually does
unbelievable
whole spiel I don't even know where he
said Natalie god damn I want to hang out
with that guy make him laugh all day
long so funny did you see the Cavanaugh
thing that Matt Damon did the [ __ ]
hardest laugh is when he came out and
they were like mr. Cavanaugh and he just
goes what that [ __ ] made me laugh so
hard anyway back to the [ __ ]
calendars laughs speaking of basketball
though
how about [ __ ] is it jr. Smith is
that the guy's name the 75 year old in
the NBA right that guy dude got this
[ __ ] was the best he got a supreme
tattoo dude on his calf all right and
they're gonna find they're gonna find
him keep that up they're gonna find him
every every game it's exposed what a
[ __ ] dunce hey junior Smith you can't
freely advertise [ __ ] on your body when
millions people are gonna watch it when
you play for [ __ ] cooperate and dude
this is what he said on the thing so I
was informed today that I would be four
by the way like he's educating us hey
man we know so I was informed today that
I would be fine to every game if I
didn't cover up my supreme tattoo on my
leg during games crying face emoji a
crying face emoji a crying face emoji a
crying laughing these people in the
league office are something else middle
finger hey man no you're in the wrong
how could you be that stupid - it's one
thing to be like I'm gonna get to tattoo
anyway
but how can you possibly get the supreme
tattoo not realize you're going to be
fine
then think then when you're going to get
fined
get up indignant about it like oh these
[ __ ] are something else dude
you work for them there's a [ __ ]
dress code for Christ's sake
I mean what the [ __ ]
how can someone you know what that how
can someone honestly give you a whole
spiel
how can someone I don't even know dude
how can you think that I don't even know
what you see in it well dude you you're
a man I'm gonna get a supreme tattoo on
my on my leg oh cool
hey the NBA is gonna find me what are
you [ __ ] kidding me these
[ __ ] are something else the
whole world well hey hey his laugh
sounds like he's in rewind dude jr.
Smith is something else man that's
hilarious hey man you got a supreme
tattoo that's a company you're playing
for a company you can't do that loving
it dude but up up I uh dude
loosey-goosey time that's all I'm down
for a sylia I'm down for a [ __ ] silly
goose time and that's it is that what I
said I think that's what I said how
about this man if you're watching the
video podcast you get to see our new
artwork man we just got the [ __ ]
Eagle right there it does it's not
really a tired eagle but it shows up
it's you know the reference in reference
to that we still got the kuda and we got
the [ __ ] congratulations log-cabin
signed by kathleen somebody I think I
still got a look really shitty uns too
disrespectful [ __ ] man I start work I
hung it up and I [ __ ] gotta check the
[ __ ] handle anyway I was in Philly
dude these [ __ ] shows have been
awesome I'm really happy I was in oh
well let me say okay I was in where was
I first
follow ya buffalo great show Vermont it
was okay
Philly two shows sold out but a bing
bada boom they were great they were
awesome dude they were awesome we had a
great time in Philly and everybody was
[ __ ] they were great
dude Philly comes I love still I wish I
did more shows in Philly they both sold
out early on I could have done probably
more but it was a casino [ __ ] clickety
clack clickety clickety Clank the money
goes into my piggy bank clickety clack
clickety Clank more money more money
with these casinos yeah remember that
song by [ __ ] dude how wide is it by
the way to call 50 cent fitty cent that
[ __ ] when I heard [ __ ] white people do
that I would get so angry when 50 cent
first came out no but it's fitty cent no
it's not you're being a [ __ ] idiot
clickety-click clickety-click the money
goes into my piggy bank $0.50 this [ __ ]
made me laugh so hard dude
this song gotta get I can't eat I gotta
get [ __ ] goddamn YouTube bread man
all these [ __ ] ads I gotta get it I
gotta get it one fire make me get it
afterwards it doesn't matter I could get
[ __ ] YouTube bread right now and it
wouldn't make a [ __ ] dude you think I
can't [ __ ] afford here it is Oh
dude come on my knife touch your skin my
knife cut your skin I love her rappers
rap about the [ __ ] and literally it
never happens funny I don't know where
the [ __ ] it is anyway he does that I
can't find it but clickety-click
clickety-click the money goes into my
piggy bank oh my god
anyway I did [ __ ] two shows at this
casino at the sugar house and it was
awesome dude the guys were so nice
she'll come out to see a
follow-the-leader tour and if you do if
you come out to the follow to the tour I
guarantee to make you laugh realer than
this well isn't it amazing what could
just happen all of a sudden and then
it's a huge thing like that [ __ ]
Kawhi Leonard [ __ ] that's awesome dude
you're just living life hanging out
having a good time and all of a sudden
he just blesses up with blesses us with
some [ __ ] way and we get to [ __ ]
laugh at that with our fellows dude
that's awesome
hey guys I want to talk to you about
quip when you walk down the toothbrush
aisle at the store it doesn't take long
to realize there are lots of options and
many of them are gimmicks dude you don't
want that the truth is you really just
need something that guides this simple
habits most of us get wrong when
brushing our teeth and quip knows that
for starters quip is an electric
toothbrush that is a fraction of the
cost of bulkier brushes while still
packing just the right amount of
vibrations to help clean your
quips built-in timer helps you clean for
the dentist recommended two minutes with
guiding pulses that remind you when to
switch sides that's been really helpful
for me because I'll just like
dilly-dally and do what I think is right
but there's an actual way to brush your
teeth and you're not doing it right so
quip helps that the subscription plans
are for your health not just convenience
they deliver new brush heads on a
dentist recommended schedule every three
months for just five dollars including
free shipping worldwide it's very
hygienic and you can travel wherever you
take your teeth which is everywhere
because your teeth party body
everyone loves quip they were on Oprah
Zola's name Times Best Inventions and is
the first subscription electric
toothbrush accepted by the American
Dental Association quip starts at just
25 dollars and if you go to get clip
comm / Congrats right now you'll get
your first refill pack free with a quip
electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack free at
get quip Calm / Congrats spelled GE tqu
IP comm / Congrats
clickety-click clickety-click the money
goes into my piggy bank stitch fix is an
online personal styling service that
finds and delivers clothes shoes and
accessories to fit your body budget and
lifestyle just go to stitch fix dot-com
/ Congrats and tell them your sizes what
styles you like and how much you want to
spend on each item you'll be paired with
your very own personal stylist who will
hand pick five items to send right to
your door then you try them on pay only
for what you love and return the rest
shipping exchanges and returns are
always free there's no subscription
required you can sign up to receive
scheduled shipments or get your fix
whenever you want stitch fixes styling
fee is only $20 even though you'd think
it would be $14,000 it's not it's $20 so
it's applied towards anything you keep
from your shipment get started now at
stitch fixed comm / Congrats and you'll
get an extra $25 off when you keep all
five items in your box that stitch
calm / congrats to get started today
stitch fix calm / congrats square cache
let me turn up this fan here square
cache you already know the cache app is
the number one finance app in the App
Store what you might not know is that
you can also put cash app in your wallet
with the cash card it's the only debit
card that offers instant rewards and
comes packed with premium features not
even a credit card can offer like boosts
save up to 10% instantly at Whole Foods
Wendy's or Chipotle and more of your
favorite spots or even $1 off coffee
every time you swipe your cash card at
coffee shops across the country the cash
card puts you in control of your money
with extra in-app safety features that
let you pause your card with a touch
unlike a credit card there are no fees
ever and a credit check isn't required
to get one download cash app now and get
your cash card for free visit the App
Store or Google Play market now and of
course when you download the cash app
and enter the referral code congrats
you'll receive $5 and the cash app will
send $5 - times up Legal Defense Fund a
true win-win you get to feel good about
yourself and it's good for you um had to
turn the bladeless fan up a little bit
because daddy's getting the [ __ ] a
little bit of some you know beads
dripping down the [ __ ] black diamond
ski course so anyway uh I was the the
weekend from Buffalo Vermont in Philly
and this guy came up to me I was waiting
for my bags
first of all Mario Lopez was on my
flight I know him I didn't know until we
were leaving and I feel bad I hope he
didn't think I was trying to [ __ ] not
say hi to him I actually tried to get
his I can take wave at him buddy yet on
these [ __ ] aviator sunglasses I don't
know where he was looking so I just
looked like a [ __ ] fool waving at
somebody that's like more famous than me
and somebody and people probably saw
like okay we're in the fame Club right
no okay never mind
people people just uh ya know
looked at me like you're not as famous
as that guy yeah yeah no I know I know I
thought I know I'm it's all good we
actually did a movie together but it's
anyway that doesn't matter mm-hmm
so so he was on flight and I was in the
baggage claim waiting for my [ __ ]
waiting for my [ __ ] way too many bags
and this guy came out to me was like hey
man we met through yada yada didn't even
remember who the [ __ ] person was that we
met through but it didn't matter and I
was like how cool we started talking and
he was like is there any way we started
talking we're talking business now we're
talking business the guy's trying to
[ __ ] approach me about business which
is fine it's not how you do it but it's
fine and this fan comes up and he's like
hey man cut immediately in the middle of
me talking can you it can I get a
picture and I say oh yeah well give me
one second man I'm talking to uh I'm
talking to uh I'm in the middle of
something and he goes I guess ah and
walks away like dude what I'm in the
middle of a conversation you interrupted
us and me in the middle of my sentence
literally I say yeah give me a second
because I didn't want to be rude to the
guy I was talking to and this guy see
that's the that's the thing about these
[ __ ] cell phone cameras it happens
all the time people ask for pictures
they don't even know who you are they
just recognize you you know only real
fans should ask for a picture okay and
don't come up and be like hey sorry to
bother you because you're not just do it
quick if you're gonna do it do it quick
I get it you want to pick cool I'm happy
to oblige
right but uh this guy was such an
[ __ ] like yeah I want to pick but not
not bad enough to wait around like you
know like can I interrupt you now like
that's the problem with [ __ ] people
who want pictures man it was so [ __ ]
egregious and such he was such an ass
and I was trying to be polite to the
[ __ ] I was talking to you got to be so
nice and friendly otherwise people think
that you're a dick anyway so it's not
even worth it man half the people I take
pictures with come out they're like ah
man
I don't know I think that people feel
like I should be happy that they're
asking me for my picture I guess I don't
know I'm happy they know who I am I'm a
happy that they're fans but I think most
people ask for pictures for me they're
not even fans they're just like want to
get a picture too should put it on
Instagram to show people that they got
it and I'm talking about yeah it was
[ __ ] unbelievable that that guy did
that that was amazing
I don't know I don't even know more dude
have you guys seen that [ __ ] video
the [ __ ] ice cream video dive the ice
cream taster were the guy this is the
one of the best videos on the internet
and I can't believe I've never talked
about this before but I [ __ ] was
sending it we were talking the group
chat and it was just [ __ ] come on man
it was just [ __ ] unbelievable
ice-cream test taste our test ate ice
cream taster dude I'm he keeps doing
that it's s gross that's a tip now
that's a 10 this this guy right here
so in tasting we do is take a small
amount right off the top first of all
this guy is an ice cream taster that's
his [ __ ] job
he tastes ice cream and it's so [ __ ]
[ __ ] I can't even believe it
doesn't take much that's the warmest
part right here let's just start this
over again so in tasting what we do is
take a small amount right off the top
first of all so with tasting what we do
is saqqaq number one we hey buddy this
is you anytime someone refers to
themselves as we flagrant [ __ ] foul
flagrant [ __ ] foul okay you might be
talking to a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I
don't mean that in a gay way I just mean
you're a [ __ ] flagrant [ __ ] foul
number one take much that's the warmest
part right here I'm gonna invert the
spoon
okay he talks about inverting this spoon
like it's his goddamn innovation and an
idea
flagrant [ __ ] foul that's too flagrant
[ __ ] fouls in the middle by the way it's
been 11 seconds okay so let's go here we
go yeah here we go
so in tasting what we do is take a small
amount like a [ __ ] it doesn't take much
that's the warmest part right here I'm
gonna invert the spoon like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay okay okay he starts about mm-hmm
now I will say here's the deal if you
take a taste of something and you go mmm
that's okay it's okay it's a natural
kind of thing mmm that's good
mmm mmm that's good right if you go like
that you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] okay I
wouldn't say it's a [ __ ] coverall 9000
tastebuds Oh so [ __ ] saying that there's
nine thousand tastebuds and want you to
know that he knows so flagrant [ __ ] call
number three covers all 9000 tastebuds I
mean how could this guy be such a
[ __ ] also couldn't look more like a
[ __ ] allergist the guy couldn't look
more like the guy I went to go when I
thought I was allergic something to
something I went to go see what I was
allergic to because I [ __ ] broke out
and this is the guy living he lives this
is what it looks like but when tasting
what we do is take a small amount by the
way go [ __ ] yourself with your white lab
coat dude what's up with ice cream guys
treating it like it's surgery every time
you see an ice cream guy like on on a
[ __ ] some sort of news brief or like
some kind of thing where you're looking
learning about ice cream the guy's
always got a [ __ ] lab coat on like he
should like like he's a [ __ ]
physician and he's always wearing a dot
a [ __ ] patch Adams bowtie go [ __ ]
yourself dude hey man
not a pharmacist you're tasting you
[ __ ] fat slob even if you're not a fat
slob you fat slob cuz you taste that's
what you do your job is going like this
irrigate it you [ __ ] [ __ ] invert this
boot what we're gonna want to do is
invert this boot and we're gonna want it
he ate it dude are you a gopher you're a
gopher in a lab coat it doesn't take
much that's the warmest part right here
I'm gonna invert the spoon mmm cover all
9000 tastebud area it warm it up driving
up that top go Oh
driving up with his hand on his [ __ ]
brain driving up driving up that top
note oh that top note like it's a
symphony of flavors you know he said
that before too well it's a symphony of
flavor of flavors dude Oh
first of all take off your goddamn
laughs lab coat do it shirtless so you
can show us show us that belly that the
ice cream gave you shirtless if you're
an ice cream taster you got to go
[ __ ] shirtless dude otherwise you
ain't [ __ ] ja rule it up baby you don't
be the [ __ ] ja Rule it up go
shirtless man be the [ __ ] Bert
Kreischer of [ __ ] eating ice cream do
not put a shirt on ain't pure vanilla
sweeteners and that's a 10 I mean how
many times does he let's count with
somebody I want somebody to count how
many times does that I be tasting what
we do any true baby a small amount right
off the tonita camera it doesn't take
much that's the warmest part right here
I'm gonna invert the spoon mmm
cover all 9,000 takes but enough Monica
area it warm it up driving up that top
nope ah that cream pure vanilla
sweeteners here's a 10
there's this thing there's this catch
price you know Dez that's a 10 that's
what he waits the whole time to do that
that's a tenth and then listen to how
many times he doesn't after that's a ten
when he's done tasting by the way here
10 Oh
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 he does it seven times
after he says that's a 10 that's a 10 so
gross jerking off you know that's a 10
that's what he does after he busses not
you have to be Berbers he goes that's a
10 that's what he does when he's making
love to his [ __ ] wife for sure dude
oh and the top off that whole video he's
got a gold spoon if you didn't
understand he was a [ __ ] yet a
[ __ ] he's got a gold spoon I like to
think that he keeps that [ __ ] dumbass
spoon in his [ __ ] lab coat and just
whenever he needs it do you need me to
taste okay here we go open it up let me
taste it now invert the spoon we're
gonna want to invert the spoon mm-hmm
now taste it aerate it
that top note symphony of flavor now
pure vanilla sweetener that's a 10
that's a 10 do it's so gross the whole
[ __ ] thing is so gross dude imagine
being a [ __ ] ice cream taster you're
gross you know we went to college to
like he went to [ __ ] you University
of [ __ ] West Virginia or some [ __ ]
and they just this [ __ ] dude jobs
that aren't jobs are the best you know
like [ __ ] jobs that aren't jobs
should only be in movies
how about movies like that though about
that like that like the movie hitch you
know
movies like that drive me nuts where
there's a fake job well it's like yeah I
get people get together people that get
together you looking to get a girlfriend
I'll find one for you like that's not a
job dude
there's online dating sites hitch okay
so he's a guy who it's his job to find a
[ __ ] mate for another guy and then
there's that one scene where he's like
hey man I need you to help me get laid
he's like whoa whoa what get laid that's
not what this is about so the movie has
some [ __ ] heart get out of town dude
and then there's that [ __ ] movie that
Kevin Hart one though is it the The
Wedding ringer where he's like where
he's like trying to be where he's the
best man worried the best man like
that's a job that's not a job the whole
[ __ ] movies about I was supposed to
be in that movie and I couldn't do it
because it's scheduling so I probably
shouldn't yeah I'm not talking [ __ ]
about it I'm sure it's [ __ ] funny but
uh it's also directed by my friend so
oops but um it killed it killed it the
[ __ ] box office I'm sure it's
hilarious so but it's so funny man the
movies about like yeah dude make a movie
about a guy who's [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm not
gonna be able to think of something my
comedy mind you know I don't know
whatever all I'm trying to say we ate it
dude that [ __ ] thing is hilarious we
have a you know what we have that you
guys are probably going to maybe like
hear that we haven't had and
while we've got a most [ __ ] up
Instagram post to the week you guys it's
time for the most [ __ ] up Instagram
post of the week alright guys it's been
a while since we've had a most [ __ ] up
Instagram post of the week but boy do we
have a good one today as a matter of
fact I saw this for some reason I saw it
on even remember how I saw it
and when then when I did see it I
thought we got a revive most [ __ ] up
Instagram post of the week was me I'm
doing what done a while so that's how
[ __ ] up this one is this is the most
[ __ ] up Instagram post of the past
however long it's been not gonna tell
you the guy's [ __ ] name because don't
want to blast him out but this is what
the poster is of him kicking back on the
roof of a building and he's got one foot
up on the wall and one foot one hand up
on his face and one hand holding his
sunglasses okay to his side and his hair
hair is blowing in the wind and he's got
perfect amount of [ __ ] and facial
hair we are living we are young let's
just seize the moment and talk about the
rest later let's do everything we want
Sulli go let's do anything they call
forbidden Sulli go let's discover
everything they don't describe as normal
let's breathe and live our lives
entirely we are blessed to be alive and
we all have the opportunity to do
everything we want no we don't so you
win heck dude turn round step outside to
dunk say yeah eat goat now that's a
congratulations combo I didn't realize
you just what's that what is that it's a
sausage is it pancakes eggs
oh dude let me take your order because
you're at Denny's and you just got
served an all-american Grand Slam
that'll be 998
let's do he's to everything we don't
describe as normal in the mean that the
meantime the [ __ ] post couldn't be
more north
couldn't be more normal
I don't know man un-fuckin'-believable
these people the most Instagram most
most [ __ ] up Instagram posts of the
week yeah you know what we also are
going to do a new Elder that's what
we're gonna do and here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna take this [ __ ]
sign off here and we're gonna give since
I've been disrespecting the [ __ ] out of
this chick because I haven't said her
name right we're going to give her
eldership for for making decor for the
for the for the log cabin studio here
her name is Catherine R Hutchinson now
she's probably got an Instagram or
something I thought it was on the back
here it's not but it says for Christa
Lea from your true baby Catherine r
hutchinson that's what it says back
there showing you on the [ __ ] video
podcast so I'm not gonna be able to hang
this back up again because I'm a piece
of [ __ ] but okay cool so you're an elder
thank you very much for your dedication
and for your artwork in helping us
secure and a beautiful visual
representation for our podcast because
this is this is great this is exactly
what what an elder what you get for
don't need to do outlandish [ __ ] like
take a [ __ ] on your neighbor's patio and
in the name of you know the cult you
don't need to do some crazy [ __ ] you
also don't need to do that much work but
this person I remember they told me
Catherine Catherine told me that she did
it while listening to my podcasts in
between I think she said she was at
she'd right she's like a driver or
something and she'd do it while she was
waiting for her clients or some [ __ ]
like that that's what she said anyway
very cool and thank you for that and you
are now an elder we will grow on this
cult strong you guys we really are
growing this cult strong we're trying to
do this and you guys are keep keep
coming out keep coming to the shows and
that's it that's what's up
aurilla we're have 50 minutes good
[ __ ] keep going do you guys hear the
construction by the way I don't know
maybe not
mm-hmm um actually that's a great [ __ ]
thing to talk about right there we got
Twitter questions here that's a great
one though drew at what is it drew
chains that's what that says
drew Train drew chains how [ __ ] are
those scooters people ride when they
break their foot yeah that's actually
really [ __ ] I mean dude you know what
I'm talking about where you put your
knee up on the pad and your [ __ ]
wheel around like an invalid
well you're just wheeling around like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like just take it take a
seat just relax have someone else go get
you some [ __ ] we got the basket in the
front of the [ __ ] handle you know who
would you know who's gonna be riding
around in these things for real soon
rappers rappers are gonna be [ __ ] on
in their videos with these bitch-ass I
don't know what you call them
bitch-ass [ __ ] if you break your a
break your ankle or break your foot just
sit the [ __ ] down get-get crutches I saw
somebody in crutches walk into a coffee
shop the other day and they went to go
grab the door real friend they gave up
on their crutches and just started
walking that's the other thing too if
you're gonna [ __ ] need crutches use
crutches don't [ __ ] don't show me you
don't need crutches if you have crutch
if you have crutches on your armpit you
better be using them this [ __ ] idiot
just was using crutches and then the
door was closing at the coffee bean and
then he just just started holding it and
ran towards the door and opened it you
don't need him sin doesn't need it it
doesn't need it I swear to God
compl at 6:19 he's gonna have she's
gonna have one of those soon um okay
Nick at how [ __ ] underscores to [ __ ] I
mean you know obviously listen to the
podcast what do you think the best
acting performance of all time is -
Dustin Hoffman in Rain Man yeah I mean
it's great he's great in that never saw
it
uh yeah he's so good in that never
[ __ ] saw one ain't one [ __ ] little
bit of it but yeah he's great
that's great I agree with you never saw
it [ __ ] um but yeah good job
I actually know if movie's gonna be good
or not before I [ __ ] see it I don't
need to see it or not you know I mean I
saw Braveheart I knew exactly how good
it was gonna be it was great never want
to see it again it was a [ __ ] great
movie I had a buddy in high school that
used to watch Braveheart all the time
that's weird to watch a movie like that
over and over again
hey man it's not swingers it's not
[ __ ] wedding crashers you know what I
mean how many times you got a yellow guy
how many times you got us we see a guy
scream freedom while he's getting his
[ __ ] nut sawed off the ones that come
to mind are Christian Bale in the
fighter at the end when he's given the
interview and talking about Mark
Wahlberg and he just all of a sudden
starts crying for no [ __ ] reason hey
it's a good here's the other thing too
man
these actors that like lose weight and
gain weight and all that [ __ ] stop let
the [ __ ] fat guy get the role let the
skinny guy get the role it drives me
nuts these [ __ ] actors just play the
role you're gonna play do it play the
role that looks like you when you get
you know what is like who's he playing
who's the guy that Enron not the Enron
guy but the [ __ ] Halliburton guy the
Vice was it a vice president or what the
[ __ ] was is the bald guy ya know
Christian Bale's playing them but it's
like Cheney
no not Cheney that's the [ __ ] guy
that died right
Janey Dick Cheney who am I thinking of
the guy who couldn't get his arms up
John McCain so disrespectful war vet so
disrespectful
prisoner of war Scissors rock was great
too for our country scissors about
Oklahoma guy couldn't put his arms up so
anyway dick cheney's playing I think
Kristen Bell is playing Dick Cheney yeah
and like hey don't hey man let Tom Hanks
do it hey man you know he just got fat
and shaved is it so weird but but I
think Kristen Bell's up there with
greatest actors for sure for net of now
for sure of all time maybe even the
guy's [ __ ] amazing and handsome and
he's good-looking what's God doing
divvying out all this [ __ ] but Dick
Cheney I don't know I don't know it
always kind of part of me wants to see
like you know how Tom from Tom Hanks is
playing mr. Rogers and and the picture
of mr. Rogers he looks so much like mr.
Rogers it just like part of me wants to
be like just stop take just don't just
let him do it why do you have to dye his
hair why I could do all this yeah I
don't know what it is about that that
[ __ ] bugs me
I guess cuz deep down I think of it it's
just [ __ ] you know I know you're
making stories that are great and mean a
lot to people but it's just like dude
you're just making a [ __ ] movie you
know it's from a company it's like you
just try you're basically just trying to
sell Kleenex and you're gonna dress up
like mr. Rogers I don't know I'm not
trying to take a look at [ __ ] at the
drop of a hat I'd be in the movie I'm
not saying but it's like these like
they're making a movie I'm reading this
book shoo dog by filmic night I'm almost
done but they're making a movie about it
and you know they're gonna get a guy
that looks like Phil Knight why why
nobody knows what [ __ ] Phil Knight
looks like they're gonna get a guy you
know what I mean like they're gonna get
out side by side all it really looks
like I'm who [ __ ] cares get a black
guy to do it who gives a [ __ ] get an
asian guy get a Vietnamese guy to play
[ __ ] film full night who cares who
[ __ ] cares don't even call him Phil
Knight who gives a [ __ ] don't even call
the company Nike who gives a [ __ ] it's
about the story it doesn't matter it's
not gonna be real anyway it's not based
on it is based on a real life I guess
there was a pair of there's a paraplegic
there's a [ __ ] paraplegic guy in the
movie make him walk who cares who
[ __ ] cares you know
there was one guy that's 300 pounds that
worked on the thing who cares what's it
[ __ ] matter it's about the story but
they're gonna do it they're gonna be
like oh look oh wow
see that's the thing when I posted the
thing about how that guy Oscar Isaacs is
that his name the actor eyes Oscar Isaac
that's what my mom does it plural eise's
every last name you know that your
friend Tim Thompson's its Thompson mom
yeah whatever
anyway he died mom's she his wife got
pregnant and then that's what my mom
does no matter what she'll tell me about
a pregnancy a death or somebody got
married one time swear to God she said
you know [ __ ] Lauren Stephenson's you
mean Stevens yeah
do you hear what happened no her dad was
walking went for a walk had a heart
attack and died on her wedding day
really yeah anyway she's pregnant too
that's what she said to me she hit the
[ __ ] trifecta altogether I was like
Jesus Christ I was like for a second I
was like irrigated that top note that's
a 10 unbelievable dude so yeah so anyway
what was I talk about format yeah so I'm
reading this book by the way I'm getting
sidetracked like a [ __ ] but
that's what this podcast is about my
babies you won't be in the cult we
sidetracking than the [ __ ] so we
read we I'm reading this book shoo dog
by phil knight and it's a good book
everyone flipped out it's almost that
good it's almost as good as everyone
saying it's very good
my agent gave it to me it's [ __ ] but
read it right away
it's [ __ ] but not to [ __ ] I read it all
the way but right away but saqqaq I said
I drop that [ __ ] that in fact on my
agent gave it to me anyway I read it I'm
reading it I'm almost done I'll be done
probably by the time this [ __ ]
podcast comes out but it was a it's a
really good book and it is a really good
book and it's about this guy phil knight
who started Nike and it's just
incredible I love it because this guy I
love hearing I love hearing about peep I
love hearing people
who are passionate talk about what
they're passionate about I don't give a
[ __ ] what it's about it doesn't matter
what it's about now I happen to love
shoes but this guy all he wanted to do
was [ __ ] make shoes he was a runner
he was like not one of the best on his
team in college but he was a good runner
um and he was like look I'm never gonna
be a [ __ ] track icon and then he just
got in his head that he wants to [ __ ]
go to Japan and be and and work with
this company called Tiger shoes that
that made track shoes and he wanted to
[ __ ] sell him he wanted to be the
American he wanted to sell him in the
American market and this company kept
[ __ ] him over and [ __ ] him over
and he kept on you know doing better and
better business every year until it was
like in 1980 he made like a hundred and
forty million dollars for the company
but it was like or 79 I think but it's
like the amount of [ __ ] the guy
here's the two things that stick with me
in this book dude first of all you gotta
[ __ ] love what you do otherwise
you're just not going to make it unless
you have supreme luck on your side which
nobody does so you gotta love what you
do you gotta want to do it like I was
just telling a story to a [ __ ] buddy
of mine I love stand-up so much you
can't get me offstage you can't get me
offstage I'll go on stage every [ __ ]
night you can't [ __ ] tell me not to I
will wait till I get my money if I can't
tell me nothing Oh in Senate no no no
whatever but I'll go on stage all the
time you can't tell me nothing and I
mean nothing this guy was gonna make
shoes you can't tell him nothing dude he
was gonna make shoes no matter what and
he thought about it obsessed about it he
got the shipment from Tiger in Japan and
he [ __ ] had his office in his mom's
house in his basement got all the shoes
and rolled around in him smelled them
looked at him and [ __ ] rolled around
in his shoes crazy passionate yeah yeah
but [ __ ] successful down the road
that's what happens my buddy this was
the story I was gonna tell you my buddy
who I'm not friends with anymore cuz
turned out to be bass [ __ ] we were both
you know audition
I hate auditioning this guy loved
auditioning he was like dude every it's
my time it's my time of the week to act
sometimes I only have two auditions one
audition a week but that's my time so I
rehearsed he loved going on what the
material was he'd break it down and go
in and that was his moment whether he's
in there for five minutes or twenty five
minutes that was his moment of the week
to shine and he loved it and he booked
stuff and I didn't and once I got on
stage as a comedian I understood I'm the
comedian bro I'm gonna be successful as
comedian because that's what I do I love
it I happen to have some sort of a
talent for it and I [ __ ] between those
two things with a little bit of luck you
[ __ ] get it go in my babies you get a
[ __ ] going make your [ __ ] hobby
your job then you'll never be upset well
you won't never be upset but you'll be
happy with what you do for your [ __ ]
for a living you know it's like I'm
trying to tell these [ __ ] dude
this guy loves tasted I screamed
he ate it he made his hobby his [ __ ]
job mm-hmm that pop nope
he made it his job to taste ice cream
I'm sure that was a [ __ ] hard road
was it or was he just a [ __ ] fat guy
that put on a lab coat who knows that
could be the little bit of luck but you
got to [ __ ] work hard that's a 10 he
came up with a catchphrase for [ __ ]
sake dude now that's a 10 now that's a
10 killing it babies make your hobby
your job you never work a day in your
life that's the saying right just you
know it's incredible man but anyway it's
a good book I can't okay so the two
things that stuck with me or how
passionate it was about what he did and
how [ __ ] many obstacles and
hurdles you have to [ __ ] get over it
was unbelievable dude every other page
is like and then this happened and I'm
getting mad reading this [ __ ] book Oh
Mike this guy just wants to make a
[ __ ] shoe dude he just wants to get
[ __ ] he literally wanted runners to
run faster and he wanted to get shoes I
mean maybe he's if what he called it
psychopath I don't know but all he
wanted to do was [ __ ] make people run
faster in sell shoes that's all he
wanted to do he wanted to better the
shoes if the shoes were
bad he would recall him and make him
better and take a hit from the company
but that's all he wanted to [ __ ] do
and the government literally the
American government was trying to stop
him threat of free enterprise my babies
but they were trying to stop him but do
I know what free enterprise means no but
I know that the book said it and I know
that that's the thing they were trying
to stop him dude the [ __ ] government
was trying to stop him
Japanese dudes were trying to stop him
in Japan people in [ __ ] other other
people in Oregon were trying to stop him
other companies Adidas Puma they were
trying to bury him converse they were
trying to bury him but [ __ ] this
dude rose out of the ashes man that's
what happened he did it he did it my
babies now Nike is a household name
that's the [ __ ] dude
that's the American [ __ ] even though
it's largely Japan and they're made in
China now in sweatshops still ha this
person right here baby face fat boy at
background Mitch hey change it change
one of them change both of them URI ate
it
can't wait till somebody changes their
name to aerate it
of course they will that top note now
that's a 10 listen to all 87 episodes in
two weeks this cult is a full-time job
to me and I'm ready for the log cabin
that's [ __ ] crazy 87 episodes in two
weeks
hey man let me ask you a quick question
to do what about family what about how
about this what about anything
background Mitch that's crazy dude hey
babyface Fat Boy Chu down dude let me
tell you something dude you're what you
listen to every [ __ ] episode in two
weeks I got a message for you
go outside
and [ __ ] Yuri ate it that's crazy
that's crazy oh my god do it did you did
you listen to the [ __ ] episode 10 and
you go that's a 10 so dumb so dumb worst
joke I've ever made on this podcast a
hundred percent worst joke I've ever
made on this podcast I don't give a [ __ ]
did you listen episode 10 and go like
this now that's a 10 worst joke ever
made on this podcast and I don't give a
[ __ ] dude you with me till the end
how about to park would do that like he
would be like that's so funny that he'd
be so gangster and then all of a sudden
ladder like he's on a tricycle hey well
it's about that time to wrap up my
babies that's what I'm trying to tell
you is we got Miami coming up
krisily accom get that followed
leadership download the cash app for
free on the App Store or Google Play
market enter rewards code congrats get
$5 and give $5 - times up also you can
hear my pod couture you can watch my
podcast on my app live before anyone
else if you download my app go to
Crystal Leah in the App Store and you
can do that and you know that's what
true babies do at least anyway I'm not
trying to pressure you but that's what
your babies do I not trying to pressure
it but that's what your babies do
Washington DC does were all sold out
sold out so now it's a car Jacksonville
Florida West Palm Beach Florida Atlanta
Georgia
West Palm Beach Florida Jacksonville
Florida Miami Florida Atlanta Georgia
Los Angeles we just added a new show get
your tickets babies San Francisco I
think that's sold out Boston Fresno
Boston I'm adding another show in Boston
in Medford just because your babies keep
trying to come out for shows sold out at
The Wiltern Wiltern no Wilbur boyacá
right blocka blocka right dude for shows
at The Wiltern blocka blocka blocka
blocka I'm Jamaican Fresno California
Bakersfield California Austin Texas San
Antonio Texas merch right we got a three
stock it's all restocked today you want
to go get those [ __ ] dahlias Grand
Slam t-shirts or the [ __ ] whatever
you want to go get go get its fall
double up on the
[ __ ] layers okay I'm also doing a
show tomorrow which is Wednesday so if
it's vo parka circuses tonight in
Ventura California go to Brian Collins
Instagram and [ __ ] click on his
stupid ass shitty a granddad link but uh
there's like it's like a really small
secret show I'm doing with Callen my
grandpa Callen anyway follow the leader
buy tickets at Chris D'Elia calm hey
look you guys we've been like number 13
on the [ __ ] Apple [ __ ] I want to get
higher all right spread the word please
I'm so sick and tired of seeing all
these [ __ ] getting jump get the
jump on us you know subscribe rate and
review the show please that helps go
onto iTunes and do that rate and review
the show really help listen to it and
also shout out to sort and scale popular
podcast episode 123 if you listen to it
you'll notice one of your [ __ ]
favorite podcasters and comedians doing
one of the voices about a guy who who
[ __ ] well about a guy who killed him
rape someone which is very shitty but
but they asked me to do it and I did it
so I played it and video episodes go up
Tuesday's or Wednesdays and subscribe
rate and review the show and go get
tickets a crystal a dark homie crystal
they are my babies and remember don't
ever forget to hear it
[Music]
you